you mentioned in the film that you do
suffer from ptsd that you do have
sometimes trouble sleeping because of
some of the images that you've seen and
that other photojournalists who've
either been on the front lines in iraq
or wherever also go through the same
thing can you talk about that when that
first started and how you handle it and
continue with this beautiful work sure
there are a lot of journalists around
the globe who are witnessing atrocities
and
we embed ourselves and we see it for
long periods of time
and that of course of course the natural
response i think is to have a really big
emotional toll
uh on on a lot of us so
that's what happened to me and i
realized one morning waking up that the
first thought in my head was of a pig in
a gestation crate and no one should wake
up with that as the first thought in
their head and so i sought some some
help and that was great and she gave me
through therapy gave me some tools to
get out of that rut
we get in all sorts of ruts and so mine
was always thinking about my work and
the awful things happening so instead of
just being in that rut and living there
she gave me tools to to refocus and and
to identify uh when i was just living in
a state of of trauma
so i now have the tools to to not live
that way and activists
this comes back to you know not just me
and journalists but empathetic people
who know what's going on and how much
suffering there is and we really carry
the weight of that but you can't you
can't flourish and you can't be happy uh
in a general way when you're when you're
feeling those things all the time so
there are tools and we need to we need
to think about you know
being happy and working on that whatever
it means to you lots of time to yourself
community
um sleeping enough
anything that you need to be happy we
need to we need to do that and we
we think how can i be happy when there's
so much suffering but the fact is that
people burn out it's a very real thing
people burn out and
compassion fatigue and then they can't
be effective
whether you know as spokespersons or
active activists in the field so we
really and i learned i learned the hard
way we really need to look after
ourselves as journalists as activists so
that we can continue on these great
missions that we're on
you